hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about surface area to volume
ratios this topic is particularly
important in ap biology first let's talk
about the definition surface area to
volume ratio is the amount of surface
area per unit of volume in a cell so the
amount of surface area per the unit of
volume in a cell it's important because
it sets upper limits on the size of
cells what this means is that a cell if
it gets too large won't have enough
surface area to meet its metabolic
requirements so if the volume becomes
too large the surface area becomes too
small the surface area to volume ratio
gets smaller and this is not good for
the cell a higher surface area to volume
ratio means two things for the cell it
means the cell can get more nutrients in
and the cell can get more waste out so
when a cell has more surface area per
unit of volume this is a good thing
smaller cells have that they have less
volume per surface area or more surface
area per volume now let's look at some
examples I have drawn two cells here
they are C Racal one has a radius of
five microns one has a radius of 10
microns if we calculate their surface
area and their volume using the correct
equations that is 4 PI R squared for
surface area and 4/3 PI R cubed for
volume we then take the surface area
divided by the volume to get the surface
area to volume ratio so for the
five micron radius cell the surface area
to volume ratio is 0.6 for the larger
style with a radius of 10 microns the
surface area to volume ratio is smaller
it's 0.3 so what that means is that the
smaller cell has more surface area per
unit of volume than the larger cell now
let's look at a way that the body can
create cells with extra surface area
when needed the best example of this is
the cells lining the small intestines
here I have drawn these cells each one
is in a different color to allow you to
see them better the black dots are the
nutrients that have been digested by the
digestive system and these cells that
line the small intestines it's their job
to bring in the digested nutrients into
the cell so to absorb the nutrients what
they do is they have this layer that is
called a brush border
the brush border is made up of cell
appendages called microvilli so each one
of these finger-like protrusions is a
micro bellows
so micro billa's is singular micro villi
is plural and you can see that all of
these finger-like projections out of the
cell greatly increase each cells surface
area and they allow the brush border of
the lining of the small intestines to
absorb nutrients much more effectively
because they have that larger surface
area and in turn a higher surface area
to volume ratio so this is why this
concept is important it's all about how
cells are able to meet their metabolic
requirements for bringing nutrients in
and also getting wastes out so that is
it for this episode of biology professor
I hope you learned a lot and thanks for
watching